and just some breaking news uh coming
out of Moscow and Russia is saying uh or
claiming that it has intercepted two
British fighter jets
um over the Black Sea that's according
to the Russian uh defense Ministry they
say the Jets did not enter Russian
airspace but Daddy we should report
these as Russia
um sorry we um but the Russians wanted
to uh
um make uh those claims tonight and it's
uh it is all rather a bit confusing but
a pair of su-27 fighter jets on duty
scrambled to identify uh the aerial
targets and prevent violations of the
state border of the Russian Federation
it's rather a complicated statement from
the Russians